[Music]
okay what up guys did you hear that
i swore i don't know if anyone heard
that
um
okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um put a one in
the chat if you can hear me put a one in
the chat
you already know how it is with the
audio issues on this channel
one in the chat if you can hear me
um
so
popular demand okay by popular demand i
have been asked to do a call-in show
okay
a bunch of ones in the chat great great
great
hi popular demand i have been asked to
do a call-in show
so
um i asked everybody when i should do it
and this was the time so thank you for
having me stay up till 2 30 in the
morning
um our time but for you guys i'll do it
all right
now
now um as a thank you i really would
like you guys
to like the video okay
bro this is what you want okay
i wanted to do a call-in show not at 2
30 and then okay look it okay
it doesn't matter doesn't matter okay
so i would like everyone to like the
video because it really does help with
the algorithm
okay now today
we are talking about bro versus wade
um
so
what
what went on right guys what what went
on today
so basically actually i'm going to pull
up should i pull up an article
hold up one in the chat if i should pull
up an article
decision
okay so
bro versus wade u.s supreme court ends
the constitutional right to an abortion
millions of women in the u.s will lose
the constitutional right to an abortion
after the supreme court overturned it
50-year-old roe versus wade decision the
judgment paves the way for individual
states to ban the procedure
half of the inspect half are expected to
introduce new restrictions on bans 13
have already passed so-called trigger
laws to automatically outlaw abortion
joe biden
described it as a tragic error and urged
states to elect laws to laws to still
allow the procedure after the supreme
court ruling abortion access is expected
to be cut off for about 36 million women
of reproductive age
according to research from planned
parenthood a health care organization
that provides abortions
demonstrations from both sides have
gathered out outside the court with
police keeping them apart
okay so
this is this is what we got going on so
i was doing a little research on this
topic right so i was like
i should i should do some research so
the states that allegedly will be an
abortion according to
gut matcher institute
alibo alabama and this is ban or like
total near total ban that's what it says
alabama arizona arkansas georgia idaho
iowa kentucky louisiana michigan
mississippi missouri north dakota ohio
oklahoma south carolina south dakota
tennessee texas utah west virginia
wisconsin and wyoming so i'd like to be
clear guys this is not a total ban as
some people are saying
you can still you know get in your car
drive a state away and do the same thing
but
what this did for me was it begs the
question okay
should
should the child
have rights
is this
is this a woman's right is it a woman's
right to true choose
is it a woman's right to choose
so what i'd like to do
okay i put the call in link in the chat
i'd really like to talk to women i'm
going to open it up to men at the end
but i just
i'm just i'm trying to talk to some
ladies okay
also if you hear my dog she might start
snoring i don't know
but preferably women agree with me
disagree let me know
come come in the chat come in the chat
do you guys like my new profile picture
i was trying to look more classy
also sign up for our memberships for
exclusive behind-the-scenes content me
ish and jess hang out all the time
and we do vlogs and stuff so
we should have a vlog posted next week
under our memberships and we're doing a
discord i don't know how to use it yet
but
yeah soon
i do have female female viewers so i'm
going to just give you guys a little bit
of back background on
my opinion right
so
personally i think that
abstinence is always an option
and also if anyone calls in and and is
doing the exception less than one
percent of abortions are used in the
cases of grape we're not talking about
that we're talking about all other
abortions
so
is this our right or can we just make
better decisions and maybe not get
pregnant
and maybe not sleep with guys
that we shouldn't be sleeping with
and if we're gonna do that
maybe require a condom i don't know
i don't know
but
let me know in the chat one in the chat
if
abortion should be banned two in the
chat if it shouldn't be banned
also i require people to have their
camera on
don't need any trolls in here
i'm trying to talk to women guys i'm
trying to talk to women um
i'm sorry i know you guys have been
requesting a mail call-in show i might
do it at the end but i really really
like to talk to women today because
i think this is a conversation that like
women need to have with women because
um the argument always is men shouldn't
have an opinion on this
like that's always the argument so i
don't agree with that personally but
um
so i'm gonna
yeah kick that
i identify as a woman
come on y'all come on ladies call in
call in
okay i'm gonna read some stats while i'm
waiting see if anyone will call in
so one argument that i've seen the
pro-choice people
make okay
um roughly speaking between 25 and 35 of
americans think abortion should always
be legal 10 to 15
think that it should never be legal and
the remaining 50 to 65 percent are split
between those
who think that it should mostly be legal
with some exceptions and mostly illegal
but with exceptions a recent gallup
survey found that for broadly available
abortions decreased from 67 percent in
the first three months of pregnancy to
36 in the first trimester to just twenty
percent of in the third twenty
percentile
i think that abortion should be legal in
the third trimester you guys are wild
you guys are wild no you don't have to
be an american because we're we're
really just talking about the right
to
choose
and pro being pro-life versus the right
to choose because
i mean we could go back and forth about
the legalities of it
you know
but we're we're really talking about is
this a woman's right
because at the end of the day it's going
to be distributed state by state
come on ladies can i you can be at
pro-life pro-choice i just want to talk
to the women i i mean i'd like to talk
to someone who disagrees
that is my goal disagrees in women
i think you need to advertise your call
on something like reddit
you you
oh how would i do that
i don't know guys
also while we're waiting like the chat
also my goal so we started this stream
i'm at
14 i'd really like to get the 145
subscribers 145. we're at 144 666
subscribers i'd really like to get to
145. so if you guys could subscribe
like the video
okay valerie i'm backstage pearl won't
take my car call you're not backstage
and you're gonna be blocked because
you're putting things that aren't true
in the chat
um
what's the number so it's not a number
it's this link it's on the screen
you just go you click it and you join
so so one argument though that i've
heard is that
basically the pub most of the public
doesn't want
it to be overturned
um
okay is this
that is a dude
not a woman i'm sorry sir that
i said girl um okay you can get
thank you for the five dollar super chat
you can get black women to support any
and all things harmful to black people
black men wake up
um
thank you for the five dollar super chat
all super chats are going towards
getting my producer a camera so when he
talks he can be on screen
okay um
but basically the
the argument is that the public opinion
on abortion
is that like that roe versus wage
shouldn't have been overturned so
why was it overturned
because remember guys it has to fall in
line with the constitution
that is the supreme court justice's job
it is to interpret the constitution
i don't know it was a dude because their
camera was on
look at guys send me your pro-choice
friends come on
i know i know y'all i know a bunch of
you guys got hoes i know you do
i know you've got side chicks hoes girls
you're sleeping with i know you do
send them this link
i know i know you got a side chick
that wants the right to choose
five dollars just because i'm awesome
what a day
what a day
i don't want to shred people i'm very
nice i'm very nice
remy i need your camera on
you don't have a
you don't have a side chick what are you
doing
i'm just kidding i'm just playing
uh remy i can't see you
i can't see i need you to go somewhere
light put your face in the camera
also i just did join someone's stream on
twitch
we were talking about trans stuff um
i don't know if you've heard of him
the worst generation maybe it's called
a ten dollars for the camera
thank you
why not insta and dual stream to youtube
like kevin samuels because i don't know
how if you know how dm me
um
okay i can't see you guys
need y'all to be in a light
light room
i need you to be looking at the camera
and i really don't mind doing call-in
shows like but the only reason i do this
is because i don't need trolls on here
remy you're not a
you're a dude
what did i tell you i said girls
who has a bear on camera someone has a
pet bear what are you doing
what are you doing
i'm pro i don't care but whitnel
liberals
weaponized skoda's first to make row
happen i don't feel bad about it being
used against them now cope
okay this is kind of funny
this is kind of funny
i'm gonna add the bear what are you
doing sir
what are you like what's going on
like i don't understand
i'm gonna kick you now but like no you
said you can squat 250 that's crazy
thank you i i definitely can
okay thank you all right have a good one
you too
like i don't what are you doing okay
just brie i need you on camera ma'am i
need you on camera
look i can see your profile picture you
look like a pretty woman
you can go on camera come on
gonna i'm gonna put the link in the chat
again
um here's 20 bucks so pearly can pay for
you academy skillshare course and you'll
learn how to dual stream from instagram
and youtube
is there one send it to me
send it to me
someone in the chat said pearl's cute
too bad she's probably a crook what the
the audacity a crook
rude
okay i'm gonna add you to the stream but
i need you to turn on
hey um brie is that your name am i here
yes my hair is all over my head
i'm laying down
can i please not be on camera
just one time all right this one this
one time yeah this one one time
i promise it's not porn
not a porn channel i i'm i'm gonna do it
because you have a little profile
picture so this one time but y'all this
isn't gonna be a regular thing chat okay
how are you
i'm well thank you thank you for having
me on i really enjoy your content
thank you so what is your opinion on
abortion is this a woman's right
and if so why
so
um no i don't think it's a woman's right
um actually i i've done it twice i've
had it i've had two abortions
but um just because i did it doesn't
make it right
so
i am on the side of life begins at
conception
um
now would i prefer
women to have the option
yeah
and i hate to be hypocritical because i
do if i had to choose a religion i would
consider myself christian
um so it's just it's it's a bunch of
hypocrisy all over the place but i'm
just saying
you know if um
if i had to
um
you know if it was allowed you know for
it to be allowed i think i think that up
to 15 weeks maybe
i don't get the whole the whole thing
went you know once they start developing
and i'm i'm not saying i'm right you
know i'm not trying to be right
i'm just trying to do how i feel
so so i just have a question so are you
i'm confused because you said you're
pro-life but it seems like you're
pro-choice because you think life begins
at conception but you think it should be
legal
um
i'm i don't have a problem with it being
legal
um the fact that you know i'm not i
don't feel like it should be easily
accessible like the fact that you know
some women may have to go over to
another state
i don't have a problem with that
um and and granted i'm full of all kinds
of contradictions on this issue only
mainly because i had to abortion so i
don't want to
you know i hate to
just be like no no no
i had
to
so you get what i'm saying yeah i don't
know
can i ask you about your abortions is
that okay
yeah
what what made you decide to get one
so the first one just being really
irresponsible
um
basically dealing with a guy and
um
just being irresponsible
same with the second one there's there
was no excuse there is no excuse i have
no excuse
okay so um do you feel like if
you knew that you couldn't have an
abortion that you would have been more
careful
that's such a great question and i asked
myself that
um a few times
and i i i believe so i would have had to
be because i mean it's not like it's
been that long since it's been legal
yeah you know
um i would have had to yeah i would have
probably been way more careful and to be
honest
i knew what i was doing like i didn't
have to get pregnant
and when you know i went years without
getting pregnant so i knew what to do
not to get pregnant
um
so yeah it was just it was a situation i
was dealing with a guy
and i felt like if it happened it
happened but when it happened and he
shut me down
so quick i was like
okay
and then that's when i ran and got the
abortion because
[Music]
you know
he showed me
the door basically
what what made you um
what made you not give the kid up for
adoption
because you know that's always an option
so was it like what made you not do that
selfish selfish
you know that's all i can say there is
no excuse i'm not excusing my behavior
at all
and i know you know
women are responsible and i want to be
responsible i mean i'm 43 now so i have
two kids a 25 year old and a 13
13-year-old
okay
did you did you experience like guilt
after that at all or like do you think
about it sometimes ever
um
not really
okay because i knew that i shouldn't
have done it i knew it was i knew it was
wrong all the way around it wasn't
i had no business at all whatsoever
you know
did you do the um surgical procedure or
was it the pill
no the surgical because this was like
maybe almost 20 years ago
okay
how far
sorry go ahead go ahead
the first one was about 20 years ago and
then the second one was like
maybe 18 year
19 17 18 years so it's been a long time
i mean not saying that means anything
but
did you get the abortion at planned
parenthood
yes
do you feel like planned parenthood
markets abortions to minority
communities
um
well i mean
because i don't know if you know the i
don't know if you know that um planned
parenthood was started by a eugenicist
uh who actually i know
yeah i'm like i've done the research on
that i'm not like super
um
you know i know some i know some
information about margaret sanger
i've done a little research i'm not
saying like i'm fully invested in it but
i do know
some of the background of planned
parenthood yeah
you're gonna ask me a question and it
was a good question
i don't remember what it was
um no because i was just the what i was
thinking about now is that 80 of um
planned parenthoods are located in
minority neighborhoods
um
and i'm trying to find and if there's
evidence that suggests that it
is marketed to minority communities and
i was just curious if you
felt like that if you had any experience
with that at all
um when you say marketed
um
do you just mean
that they're in the community
because when i went to get my
second abortion at least
um it was actually in the suburbs
okay
so
yeah
okay i was just curious so you would say
no on that one go ahead
no but i mean you know i drive down a
particular street quite often and
there's a planned parenthood and they're
pro protesters outside and you know
things like that
so um
[Music]
yeah i don't
know because um
because my thing is i think if abortion
was made illegal women would be more
responsible overall
i think we would think twice between
sleeping before sweeping sleeping with a
guy that we shouldn't be sleeping with
and we know damn well wouldn't be a good
father
and
and i'm all about putting the
responsibility back on woman and to me
abortion just kind of like takes away
the responsibility from women
um and so it's interesting even hearing
from someone that's had one you'll you
almost feel the same way in a way
yeah absolutely i mean
yeah
if i didn't have that available
um
i'm i'm sure i would have
you know
did things differently um
[Music]
and like i said
anything after it um after that
like i never you know i didn't get
pregnant unless i wanted to get pregnant
you know so i know exactly what i was
doing um
and i know women that have had
triple the abortion
yeah 40 of women that have an abortion
have already had one or two before
yeah that was a question i had too like
what do do they study
how many women how many how often
and i do know women who really do rely
on abortion as a
form of birth control you know
um yeah
but it's interesting because the
narrative is always that it's like a
last resort and we had no other option
but the more i talked to people that
have had them it doesn't really seem
like that's the case
right exactly um
i knew as soon as oh i think i think you
were gonna ask me how long did i wait
oh yeah that was my question yes i
thought so yeah yeah so
um
for me
it was immediately after my first mess
period i'm not saying
i'm better
or anything like that but i i cannot
comprehend
anything waiting past you know
the time that you miss your period you
know at least a couple weeks after just
to you know make the appointment and
everything and i'm not saying this right
um
[Music]
but yeah as soon as i found out i was
like you know i wasn't waiting for arms
and legs and all that stuff i'm not
saying that i was you know any better
but i'm just saying that
for me that's what i that's how i
handled it
um and have you seen what an abortion
procedure looks like
like when you
when you went and like did you know
exactly what was going on
um not necessarily
you know it was a really pretty fast
procedure
um
but i did feel a little
i remember the second time anyway for
sure like feeling a little sluggish a
little tired just wanting to rest and
everything like that and it just took
about a day for me to you know just kind
of relax and recover
um
and i mean i know that
you know at some point
you know they they crack the skull or
however it goes
and things like that so yeah i'm
familiar with
yeah
but i've never actually seen
a
actual video first time
yeah because my my thought is i think if
more women saw what actually goes on um
i think a lot less would do it because
it's pretty gruesome if you ever look at
like the actual videos
like they literally tear the limbs out
like one by one and then crush the head
and suck everything out
yeah yeah
um and not to justify i'm not justifying
um
it's just that you know i i'm not
i'm not nearly as far as long
as or was as far as along
um
so
you know
i don't know i i just maybe and that's
maybe why i didn't have a real
connection
to it either as well
so
and that's probably why i don't think
about it as much
well i think it's easier to like i think
it's easier for women not to think about
it too much
if i'm being honest like i think um a
lot of times i think if we had all the
information less women would probably do
it
i agree
but it's interesting why why do you
still say it should be illegal or it
should be legal if you do think life
begins at conception
i guess only because
i had the opportunity to do it
do you feel like it's hypocritical
i feel like it's hypocritical for me to
just be like
you know
yeah
you know and i could be wrong i i'm you
know i'm sure i'm sure
a lot of people disagree i'm sure you
might disagree
that's just part of me feeling like
okay
you know
how can you say one thing but you did it
um
i understand
yeah
and at the end of the day i still feel
like if
it's a living being that
should you know
should be able to survive
even though i made the choice that i did
so if you want if if you hadn't had an
abortion would you be pro-life
um
i don't know
that's a good question i i really don't
i don't know
um
i would have to be because if i'm a if i
claim to be a christian i would have to
be right yeah
yeah you know so um
yeah i guess no i wouldn't be uh i mean
whatever the question is
i would be anti-abortion
because i think um
you're you're allowed to be pro-life
even if you've had an abortion because i
mean people can learn from their
mistakes and make better decisions in
the future
okay so i struggle with it
yeah
that's my internal struggle and i thank
you for sharing that and i receive that
and i recommend it thank you
well um thank you for calling in and
being honest on the call i think it's
good that we have these like open and
honest conversations so um i appreciate
you calling in you're one of my first
well thank you for taking my call and
not making me keep them up
um okay well i will talk to you later
okay thank you pearl i love your show
thank you so much have a good one and
tell your dad i said hi thanks for
watching
i'll tell him he hates the internet but
i'll tell him
okay bye-bye bye
okay y'all
in the chat who's in who's in the
waiting room what did i say
what did i say guys
girls only girls only
girls only i'm sorry guys
okay i yeah okay um
so this is the thing
i don't believe that if most women had
all the information that they would make
the same decisions
some still would
some still would but
i i personally just don't understand
like why on earth is this my right
okay i'm gonna block you because you
keep coming in and i keep telling you
it's men only it's men only
like i don't
i had two women who had abortions and i
don't have any children at 55 and it
still haunts me to this day
so
yeah this is this is something that's
really um
i'm the guy who banned abortion
i don't get it um
sorry someone put something in the chat
but this is the thing about women is i
think if women actually had to see what
an abortion procedure looked like
like i feel like less girls would do it
um and i'm not i'm not here to just like
shame women that take accountability and
say that i shouldn't have did that but
because like what are you gonna do you
can't un-abort it but
a lot of women aren't given all the
information and a lot of girls are more
reckless because
they know that abortion is a
fail-safe like guys we can practice
abstinence as women
we don't we don't have to sleep with
every guy we want to sleep with like
it's possible to have self-control
um
why is this healthcare when every woman
has the right to abstinence why
why okay
um
morbia geoffrey hey pearl big fan what i
wanted to shoot my shot i'm 5'6 so i'll
hold the l on the abortion issue i agree
that it should be illegal it's not fair
to me as a man since it's 50 my kid
that's another conversation should men
have a say
should men have a say
from your pay gap argument previously i
have another valuable
viewpoint you should use if your boss
could make 30 profit on gender alone why
would any man get hired there's a
value-provided difference look it
um
from patrick cooper thank you for your
service to black people who need
awareness from truth and sound
perspective sentience what up sentience
um to answer the caller's question
florida does track the demographics of
abortion aborting mother such as aged
reasons many states purposely do not
track it nor are they allowed to publish
it if they have it
yeah that's very true guys the black
population will be double today in the
u.s if it wasn't for abortion
margaret sanger was a eugenicist
she was literally a eugenicist
and
it's she's accomplishing her goal in
2022 the black population would be
double today
so
the question is
why no outcry why no outcry
roe versus wade was based on lied was
row never had an abortion and and
birthed all three of her children
margaret sanger quote consequences of
breeding from stock lacking human
vitality always will give us social
problems and perpetuate institutes of
charity and crime
she literally
had a
something called the n-word project that
was literally dedicated
to
eradicating
the black race so
it's just crazy how this this is what
we're in and there was there's no outcry
okay i might give in and let the men
call in
um are dnc affected by roe versus wade
decision a dnc is needed in case of an
emergent marriage
pearly what's your view on vasectomies
you can get a vasectomy i don't care
um okay let's see
another point 95 of all biologists
affirm that biological view on human
life begins at fertilization
so are we trusting the science
are we trusting the science
okay
another
data point that people get incorrect is
that abortion is for low-income women so
my question is
if it's to protect the
i thought i blocked you okay
single women who earn 47 000 plus a year
abort 32 percent of their babies single
women making 11 000 a year or less abort
8.6 of their babies
this is not about desperation and
poverty it's time to get real about that
okay since no one's calling in
you can't give in
i'm gonna i'm gonna read some other
stats that i got okay
according to the department of public
health of every state that reports
abortion by ethnicity black women
disproportionately lead in the numbers
for example in mississippi 79 of
abortions are obtained by black women in
washington dc more than 60 percent in
georgia 59.4 in alabama
58.4 percent and state after state
similar numbers are found with black
women aborting at two three or more
times their presence in the population
at every income level black women have
higher abortion rates than blacks or
hispanics this study coincides with with
historical revelations that eugenicists
dating to the mid 1900s
argued the most effective way they could
advance their agenda would be to
concentrate population control
facilities within targeted communities
the reality is that black women are
being pushed led into abortion centers
by the cater of the elitists who agreed
with frederick osborne the leading
eugenicist of the 20th century that
birth control and abortion
are turning out to be great eugenic
eugenic advances over time if they
hadn't been advanced for eugenic reasons
they would have been retar
oh gosh i don't sorry i shouldn't have
said that word
the r word or stopping their acceptance
then and now sanger's organization has
used trusted leaders to convince the
black community that abortion as a form
of birth control is not only acceptable
but but also beneficial to african
american culture
um
according to george gantt author of the
grand illusions the legacy of planned
parenthood sanger's philosophy on race
known as specific racism discriminates
against other ethnicities based on the
quality of genes in sanger's eyes
scientific racism in the case of the
black community includes skin color
grant exposes singers discriminatory
notions and documents many inflammatory
comments she made during her tenure
abortion is the leading cause of death
for african americans more than all the
other cases combined including aids
violent crimes accidents cancers heart
disease in 2008 black women had an
abortion rate at 3.5 four times higher
than white women
so
why is there no outcry
why is there no outcry
that is the question sir what did i say
i said women women only
women only
women only
like if this was nike and nike had
racist founders people would be
up in arms why is there no outcry
outcry
um okay
my point
is as a man it does affect men and we
are
and we be
because we are left out of the
conversation two dollars awareness is
key
um john smith pearl what is your view on
plan b
i don't know enough about plan b to have
a strong opinion on it
um i learned recently that someone said
it's similar to an abortion but i've
also heard it's not
so i really would like to talk to a
doctor on that if uh the kid was mixed
lighter-skinned black women
would have kids read hiding in plain
sight black women the law and the making
of the white
and jatin republic also if you hear a
weird noise that is my dog snoring in
the background the baby for a woman at
poverty level can use the baby for
financial support from the state
so
i'm going to go through some of the
arguments that i see so
does the child have any rights
in this situation when when does the
child have a right because most people i
talk to don't think that the day before
the day
before you give birth you should be able
to abort the child that's typically not
how it goes
right
typically people aren't saying that
so if that's true at what specific point
does a does a kid become a person
is it heartbeat
if it's heartbeat
is it
activity
you would say conception
should i give in should i let the men
call in
i just i really wanted to talk to women
today
indeed conception so
here's the thing about conception at the
moment of conception
there that kid has a unique dna sequence
that says things like
what eye color it will have what hair
color it'll have
is that life 95 of biologists say so
okay fine men call in
men men call in
fine
fine
stop being sexist you guys know damn
well why i'm doing it women only
fine
go ahead come back y'all can come back
women too though women too
okay the governor of virginia made
public statements that the mother could
give birth and then the doctors and the
mother could talk and to decide whether
or not to terminate
this is the problem
this is the problem
it's still just a parasite what the
you go tell a woman that just had a
miscarriage that it was just a parasite
you let me know how that goes for you
sir i need to see your face on screen
need to see your face on screen
okay
um
hello
hey there it's a good time to come on
pearly things
yeah no it's a good time how are you
let me shut off the old
thing hey okay now i can hear you
well okay so what what is yours
i'm good i'm just streaming so what is
your stance when does life begin
okay
first off uh let me introduce myself
i'm the first
king of the continent and that might
sound crazy
uh
i toppled the united states in 2014
because of this topic
uh
we have an unalienable right to life
that must be upheld by the government we
have a right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness you may have heard
that before over here
uh
see they failed to understand the
declaration of the independence for 250
years
and this is a serious crisis
like the movie idiocracy we're living in
a dumbed down society where
the supreme court
your governors presidents for decades
have failed to understand okay they're
wrong i'll ask you a question can i ask
you a question murder uh
okay okay wait so i need you to
okay okay
for the
did you say you're a king
yeah we're trying to restore dignity
back to men here because of this
feminist gynocracy that has transpired
you see uh men are putting cage for life
for mate selection
the entire continent
i started off in the pacific northwest
uh as president uh
we uh
we have endured uh a lot of things but a
suppression
in the media but you see uh
have you ever ever heard of cascadia and
seen cascadian dub flags on the west
coast
here in the states uh anyway uh the
pacific northwest
oregon territory uh oregon washington
british columbia is the origin of
cascadia and since my understanding of
chief seattle philosophy it has expanded
and enveloped the entire continent
and if you take any group of people at
random to look for leader based on
intelligence instead of popularity so
the elections in the democracy have made
a vote for someone smart instead of
someone popular
so uh popular people are hated and also
compartmentalized by big brother and big
okay so okay thank you thank you for
calling in thank you thank you for
calling in
thank you for coming in
an abortionist
okay i'm sorry
um okay i i don't know i'm sorry
um
[Music]
oh i'm sorry oh i hate doing that okay
i just
ah okay okay next present
hello
hi how are you doing
i'm good how are you i'm doing good
um so what's your take uh when does life
begin
and why
i do believe that life begins at
inception but um
birth control does like the plan b
it does um at times it'll stop the egg
from bounding to the
like
uterus
so um
that could be considered like uh
aborting to
in a sense because
that life is there
if you count like uh life
starting at conception
so so would you say it should be illegal
for all of them like that plan b should
be illegal too i mean that that wouldn't
that really wouldn't work out too well
if you try to rule out plan b as well
but um i i believe i'm actually
pro-choice i i feel like
uh women should have the right to
to choose
okay why
uh would you like me to experiment upon
that yeah yeah i said why
okay so like um
take this example that uh say example
you have a you have a kid
and your kid has a liver disease
and um actually a kidney disease sorry
kidney disease and um without their
kidney they're gonna die
um
it's your kid so
you have a right to this kid the same
way
or you have a responsibility to this kid
the same way that people say
a mother has a responsibility to the
fetus
right
if my kid has a kidney disease
yeah so like
you have a you have a they say like your
kid is your responsibility okay
like like is the kid in me or is it like
two
like how how old is the kid
with the kidneys okay the kids the kids
too the kids okay so it's like a grown
up i wasn't
so um the same way that
um you
it would be nice if you gave your kid
the kidney
you don't have the responsibility to
give your kid the kidney
you have the choice
and for that reason i feel that women
should have the choice to
like
choose if they okay do i do i have the
choice if i if i have a kid to like just
not take care of it and let it you know
is that legally should i like like so if
i have a two-year-old right a
two-year-old can't really survive
without its mom
let's make it one just to make a little
bit you know what let's make it six
months old so is that is that it's also
my choice to take care of it couldn't i
just let it like die and leave it
because it depends on me right
it'd be nice to take care of it but i
don't really have to by that logic
[Music]
what do you mean no by the logic i was
saying that it's not your responsibility
to give the child because
the kidney is part it's not my
responsibility yeah it's not my
responsibility to give it food it's part
of
no but out of my paycheck
the situation the the aspect that i'm
like
like specifying on is that it's your
kidney that you're giving to the the
baby now i do believe that like it's a
separate life but like it's a different
situation in which the life is in the
mother's body like it's a tricky
situation that's why this is like a
tricky discussion because
yes it's a life in itself and also like
it's in your body too
so you have to like
make a balance in which
so where do you think life begins then
at what point during the pregnancy
should i be able to sense since the idea
is that since it's in my body i should
have a choice the day before i give
birth should i be able to abort it
because it's in my body
but it's dependent on me
it's in my body
i mean it'd be nice of me but i don't
have to right
what do you mean
like it'd be not like the same logic
when you said you you don't have to give
them your kidney right and so i'm saying
by that logic like if if it's dependent
on me it's in the womb
would you say the mother has to give the
child her kidney
no
but i'm saying i'm saying by that logic
you're saying she should have no choice
do you think do you think the mother
like has the right to like does she have
is she obligated to do that
don't tempt me
don't tempt me i might say yeah
no no
i'm actually i'm actually i'm actually a
pro-life i was just like i thought of
that analogy and like
i like
i i didn't have an answer to that to you
but i'm like pro-life too like i
actually um
oh actually i'm not for a choice i was
just drawing you're just you're you're
just josh
yeah okay okay
have a good have a good one
what the
audacity
the audacity kicked
kicked all right um
um
which one of you looks like you're not a
troll elizabeth eliza
elizabeth
i know you're trolling put on your
camera
oh okay okay
put a camera on
hello wait you got to put on your camera
ma'am okay really okay all right fine i
look like you're pretty you're pretty
yeah what you doing what's up girl my
hair's a mess okay
hi
how are you
good how you doing
good so what do you think should we have
the right to choose is this a woman's
right
to be honest i i feel well first of all
i feel like conception is
that's that's where it ends like you
conceived and now you have a child
growing inside you
um
and i i feel like it's it should be both
the man and the woman's right because
you guys decided to sit like lay down
with each other
and i feel like since we've gotten to
that point now we forgot that we have a
choice to lay down mm-hmm you know i've
yeah i've gotten so far that we've
forgotten that you know you really don't
have to just lay down and not have
people protect yourself for themselves
and their child and everything else
that's my husband
well and that's the thing like i'm a big
believer and you made your bed lie in it
yeah you made that choice like
we have so many options we have birth
control we have
we we can require that the men we sleep
with wear condoms we have abstinence
yeah why why is that this is the only
choice that mattered what happened to
the ten choices we made before that
that's like where they actually were
these like monkeys that can't not have
sex
they think it's an easy way out
yeah using this excuse as an abortion
meanwhile they're taking a life off this
earth and throwing it in the garbage can
yeah
yeah
yeah
and and you know actually my husband and
i are
we're really passionate about it because
we're we've been trying to get pregnant
so you know and we've
you know tried and tried and had
failures so
like the moment
you get pregnant
even though people try to say it's like
just a clump of cells it's the most
magical feeling when you really want it
you know you're like wow i'm pregnant
there's a life growing inside me but
then there's people out there that are
screaming and yelling that it's a clump
of cells and they should be allowed to
throw it in the trash and it's just
terrible it really shouldn't be that way
and a lot of those women would be that
have had abortions would be devastated
if they were infertile
yeah like what if what if that was your
shot you don't know if that was your
last shot at having a kid
yeah the more abortions you have the
worse it is you're gonna get pregnant
down the road it's very true like i i
know somebody who had like a bunch
when they were younger just because they
were using it as birth control and then
when they tried to get pregnant they had
to do all these surgeries because their
uterus literally couldn't hold their
child
shut up yeah
like like i don't know what it was but
it was like
maybe some kind of like
casing or something like a swing to keep
it up like terrible like
you're destroying yourself from within
for what just so you can have
unprotected sex with every random person
it we've gotten to so desensitized and
like so hypersexualized and just so like
why
mm-hmm
well and it's they act like we have no
self-control as women and they keep
bailing us out for bad decisions
and so why would why would women make
better decisions if we keep giving keep
getting bailed out for every bad
decision that we make
and there's not even accountability on
us
yeah so i have a question if abortion
was illegal do you think that the women
should be prosecuted
if they abort yeah legally yeah yeah i
do i do too actually yeah
i i feel and i also feel like we've
we've um
you know we kind of like down down men i
know this is kind of off topic just a
little bit but we kind of doubt men a
lot like oh they're nobody they're
they're scrubs they're this they're that
but we've literally made it a point for
decades now telling men that they're no
longer needed in the family unit
by welfare and different things like
that and now abortion my body my choice
like even though it's happier child i
can scrape it into the crash like you're
basically telling these guys that
they're
not they're not needed they're they
haven't they have no say so why why
would you expect them to stand up to the
plate and act like men if you're taking
it from them bit by bit yeah that guy is
worthless
well and that's the thing like we we
can't be mad at men if that's what we
require of them men will jump through
hoops to make a girl happy they will
jump through hoops but when we keep
requiring
like if if you require nothing of a guy
then he's going to give you nothing
exactly and so we can't be mad it's the
like run around in circles for us but
they need just as much like love and
affection too like in respect
like every single human being wants
respect they want to be heard they want
to be appreciated
that includes men so why should we feel
like we can just step all over them and
then they should just like bow down to
us and kiss our feet
have you have you seen the actual like
videos of an abortion
yes i have i think a lot less women
would do it if they saw what was going
on i think they
they almost hide that oh yeah they make
it seem like over there yeah they make
it seem like a procedure instead of
pulling the limbs off of a child one by
one crushing the skull and sucking it
out yeah there there was a doctor
actually that was um testifying in front
of congress maybe i'm not i'm not really
too good with like remembering all that
kind of stuff but he was explaining
what he had to do and he had to do it
because he was a he was a doctor and he
he just so broken inside from what he
saw and he said you literally have to
re-put the baby back i mean i'm sorry to
say yeah
just to make sure you have all the peace
i mean it's terrible it's just terrible
and you're asleep you don't know you
don't know what's going on well and and
they act like if 40 of women that have
had um an abortion it's their second or
third and you don't know and you don't
know if the 60 which ones will have it
in the future
yeah i i work in a medical facility like
i i'm on the phones like answering you
know how many girls just call it plan b
plan b and it's like i could see it's
like second or third refill like it's
it's just like yeah whatever i'll just
get pregnant you know i'll just keep
doing that to my body and keep getting
rid of it
i don't really like the plan b thing
either i mean that's just a whole nother
story but i i really don't think that's
cool either
i think yeah i i don't know enough about
the whole mess of us being like running
around having sex randomly
yeah atomic bomb
that you're putting in your system to
immediately eliminate any type of
pregnancy in the first day or two yeah
i mean
what do you say
yeah i mean you don't really need any
like pre anything you just ask for it
and they give it to you
oh wow is it like you can get it at like
anywhere no you have to
know
well oh can you oh i don't know that but
i know people call to get it prescribed
i guess so they don't have to pay for it
why not the insurance will pay for it
they won't a lot of insurances won't pay
for fertility treatments
but they'll pay for you to kill your
child
wow
that's crazy
they'll pay for the testing but if you
need if you need like ivf if you need
any kind of assistance and fertility
they won't pay for it you got to pay out
of pocket
i also don't understand why there's no
outcry that planned parenthood is
literally a racist organization yeah
like it's it was literally a eugenicist
organization and they're literally
doing what they said they're gonna do
well they succeeded in gaslighting
people like they have over the over the
decades and that's why they try to shut
up the older generations
they try to make it seem like it's
uncool to listen to your elders to
respect them to heed what they say
because they're the ones who were alive
when these things were actually going
down and they remember what went down
and or people get their information now
from social media from you know all this
other kind of stuff from like
celebrities that are bought and paid for
to like push all this nonsense
and
they won't listen to their parents they
find their their role models elsewhere
well i saw this clip and it gave me the
it gave me like the shivers oh my gosh
it was margaret sanger's like grandson
and he's he's still he was the head of
planned parenthood in new york so it's
the same family
and he um they interviewed him on the
street about planned parenthood or about
the roe versus wade band and he was
going out of his way to say like oh this
disproportionately affects women of
color women of color and i'm just like
the audacity they're still doing it like
it's still a racism
um if you dm me on instagram i'll send
you the clip this was um like day or two
ago like in the last 24 hours i would
say it was a guy on the street and he
was interviewing random people and it
just happened to be margaret sanger's
grandson in new york wow
so do you think that he was like
kind of like insane like maybe he's like
against his grandmother and he was
trying to tell people or he was just
trying to act like he was innocent no i
think he was saying because
he was at they were asking him what was
um
wrong like like what his thoughts were
on it and he was saying
basically like pushing it that like this
is disproportionately
this is bad for women of color
like he's saying like this is a like
this band is going to hurt women of
color but really like
like that's a racist organization you're
putting 80 of your your
planned parenthoods in minority
neighborhoods and so it's like they're
they're doing the same thing he's still
pushing it yeah i mean yeah like he
funded the police crap like it's like
yeah but you know who that's going to
affect the people in urban areas that
have the most crime that need them we
protect them it's just it's just a
constant and and and you know and then
then you have like these politicians and
they're like we're going to have
everybody come out and scream and yell
and you know all the black women should
come out and scream and yell and it's
like how dare you like just how dare you
because you have access to so much
information and you should know what's
really behind like what's going on here
and like you said earlier like they
would probably like the black community
would probably be doubled or tripled at
this point if they if they didn't like
like strategically place planned
parenthood in their
in their um
communities
well and this is someone in the chat put
that it shouldn't be about like the
racist part but my whole point is like
why
why why isn't there an outcry about this
that this woman was a eugenicist when
there's an outcry
yeah yeah and so it's like what it's
weird
not only it's not only about race no
it's not but it but at the same time
like what you said with margaret singer
it was about race for her
so yeah and and actually the numbers
speak to that it's it's affecting the
black community and there is no outcry
and that's just kind of like hello like
like be consistent with your arguments
someone someone in the chat put 47
percent of black black pregnancies for
the last 40 years have ended in
termination like that's insane
i mean i just i get to i literally i get
the chills it's really terrible
if you dm me on instagram though um i
will i'll send you the clip it'll give
you the chills it's really gross it's
really gross yeah uh but thank you so
much for calling in uh yeah and your
husband seemed like a really cute couple
oh thank you i thank you for putting me
on camera but i love you anyway
thank you so much appreciate you yeah
oh by the way i really appreciate you i
think you're amazing young young woman
you're you're a lot younger than me so
your young woman and
just all the best and you know just keep
doing what you're doing because i think
you're excellent like i think thank you
so much
what this community needs on youtube and
i just i'm in awe of you like just the
way you speak in the and the way you
carry yourself it's amazing so thank you
so much appreciate you you're welcome
doll bye
bye
okay she was nice
um
let's see
all you do
valerie get out of here let's see
who
juliana
you got no camera
it's like ma'am
all right you know i'm gonna go to joe
oh wait
oh juliana's a girl okay i'm sorry guys
i'm sorry
hi hello can you hear me
yeah i can how are you i'm doing well
how are you
i'm good did i say your name right
giuliani
[Music]
how are you so um what is your take
abortion is it a woman's right
um my take is that it shouldn't be just
the woman's right because it's not just
her body anymore um maybe about like 10
years ago i would
would be a little bit more like
pro-choice and
always kind of lived a life of like oh i
would probably not
do it myself but i shouldn't you know
have the uh
i don't know the ego to try to tell
someone else what to do and then over
time
i realized that um
[Music]
people were even like posting about it
online and girls are like in these
offices you know having this procedure
done and
sort of like gloating about it um it was
a specific
uh like tick-tock uh compilation if you
will of all these girls that were sort
of bragging about what they were about
to do
and for some reason it struck a chord in
me and then i started putting kind of
more thought into a lot of it and
following some people online that were
pro-life instead of pro-choice and
realized that it was kind of um it's
pretty crazy
um
[Music]
so i guess yeah i don't think that you
should just be able to do whatever you
want and then you know
turn the backspace
to something like that
so do you know anyone that's had an
abortion
so when i was in high school um so that
was like maybe two thousand
six and seven i knew like maybe a
classmate or two that had to do that um
but it was very like hush hush even back
then
like girls weren't really bragging about
it so it would be something that would
be shared in secrecy it wouldn't be that
people like paraded it around as much i
guess
um and it was always something that was
regrettable and
really obvious even to their friends
that like
you know you should have probably used a
condom or been on
birth control or done any other option
um instead of having to make that choice
but
this person that i'm thinking of on top
of my head
it was you know she was young and
the guy was
i guess
at that time would have been deemed not
a very good father and she didn't want
to go through with it um so
it's it's interesting because
it seems like it's
become more of a form of birth control
rather than something that was uh it
seems like originally intended to be for
an emergency
right
but now it's it's odd like you see all
these people like that one girl like
didn't she live stream her abortion or
something
i don't think i saw that but i wouldn't
be surprised you know what i mean and
it's interesting because it's kind of
obvious why they would flip something
like that over rover suede because
the i guess the younger generation that
doesn't leave anything sacred and puts
everything on the internet kind of gave
themselves away
and if i'm only
um you know i don't mind saying i'm 32
and if i feel kind of freaked out by
that then i can only imagine like some
supreme court justice like maybe
possibly seeing that video who knows
right and being like
this might have gotten out of hand
i mean people girls aren't even ashamed
to be in that situation in the first
place let alone live streaming it
so um question what made you um switch
from pro choice it seems like you're
pro-life now right
yes
is it was it
um
mostly seeing compilations like that or
was it something else
well it was also the graphicness of it
and kind of like what you said earlier
you know it was more of a medical like
situation in emergencies and probably
i would assume in the beginning
beginning stages where they would give
you um you know uh a pill that would
essentially cause you know
a miscarriage or something like plan b
where you just take it
it starves the nutrients from the baby
yeah right right and so
i think maybe there was like a moment
where i was like oh well maybe that
would be more arguable if you caught it
really early and if it wasn't like the
thing where they are dismembering you
know something inside of you and sucking
it out
but then more and more you know
the deeper you dig
and
you find people who went under
um you know under secrecy into some of
these labs and recorded some of these
things happening and the doctors that
were doing them
and um just the graphicness of it
yeah
i think
i think um if a lot of people saw the
actual abortions like what goes on
it's i don't know if you've actually
seen videos of it but it made me sick
the first time i saw it
i mean i all i needed excuse me to see
is honestly even just like a
a diagram like that's drawn up you know
what i mean i wouldn't even need to see
the video honestly um and i think
probably the other thing
also that maybe
made me i kind of call it like almost a
bias like your previous guest um
i'm now at that age and stage where i do
want to be with child and i'm married
and stuff like that so
if i'm trying to achieve that and have
that happen for me
it's hard for me to imagine someone just
like destroying that if that happens to
them
just
exiting their pregnancy you know
well and a lot of girls don't realize
that might be their last like shot you
know like you don't know if they'll have
one later
right and you don't know if there's
going to be a complication and maybe
you'll become infer like something could
happen down the line and
you know are you going to regret that
maybe you let that kid go you know yeah
and that probably i imagine plays a
bigger picture also into just how much
people depend on like um like on birth
control too um
i tried birth control when i was really
young like 21 22 and then it really gave
me um it made me kind of crazy and
intense and i felt a little bit unhinged
and i'm like i don't like how this makes
me feel and so i just kind of dropped it
and uses used other contraceptives and
stuff like that
so when girls are going to the doctor
and the doctor's like here you need this
x y and z a lot of times they don't even
ask like how is this going to make me
feel what is the side effect of this let
alone like
them admitting like there's a potential
you could have you know
scar tissue inside of your uterus as a
result of
they're not going to say that because
they want to do it
um just like
a lot of other doctors will say
something to kind of juice it up in
order to give you a complex than need
them you know what i mean instead of
empowering them and saying like
you know you can do this and you have
support and x y and z
the whole argument of being
people being poor and not being able to
do it i also don't really believe in
that either because
my family was poor when i was young and
my parents wanted me more than anything
or my brother
so well
and it's not even a single woman who
earned 47 plus 47 000 a year abort 32
percent of their babies will single
women make that make 11 670 a year or
less only aboard eight percent so it's
actually not even the lower it's not
even like poor
the lower income that are aborting kids
interesting
yeah isn't it
um
is that because
they get like a benefit or is that
because
people or women who make more money have
more access to more freedom more
partying already so we don't want to let
go of that
i don't know i couldn't tell you sure
but it's just the narrative that
it's like mostly low-income people that
are doing it just isn't true i can't
tell you why sure
but but thank you for calling in um
thank you if you want do you want to put
in your instagram if you want people may
you know dm you say hi i don't know if
you want to put it out there you can say
it
i think i'll pass thank you though okay
have a good one
bye
bye
it's like some people were asking for
like her number or whatever in the chat
or like
i don't know some guys
were interested i was just giving her
the option
all right
hello
hey good evening pearl
how are you
i'm all right how about you
i'm good um so tell me
uh is abortion a woman's right yes or no
i would say no um
and i'll say with me i started as
pro-choice in college and i
did that because i was very feminist
and um i've grown into pro-life
primarily
by interacting with those feminists
because
when you actually speak to them about
the issue of abortion you notice that
the topic always goes to power it always
goes to a woman's control over it it's
not treated as a medical procedure
maybe even when i was pro-choice
i always looked at it as it's a medical
procedure of last resort if
something if you're um contraceptive
fails if
you're graped or if you're
step road i guess the term i'd use um
but if something bad befalls you it's
the
it's a last resort but it always came to
the forefront of the conversation as
a form of power
and even and not the last resort even
getting closer to like a first resort
so to me it's like okay is this actually
a medically necessary procedure or do we
have
seven trillion ways to present to
prevent pregnancy now and maybe we don't
need this anymore it's not the 70s
anymore
no i i agree with you i don't understand
why they treat us like we're monkeys
that can't choose abstinence a condom or
the million friends of birth control
that there are i don't understand why 40
of women um that are getting abortions
have already had one why is this a form
of birth control
why why isn't it a last resort and why
is it always advocacy for abortion why
is there never advocacy for say premium
reimbursement programs for birth control
um or proper sex education or even free
condom distributions in low-income
neighborhoods somewhere
adoption
adoption too like there's so many
options that people don't
and then the other argument that i hear
is that like
they don't want the kids to grow up poor
and maybe the parents aren't ready but
it's like
are poor kids less valuable is that the
argument we're going here it's a
slippery slope
i mean i grew up i didn't grow up in the
greatest conditions and i wouldn't know
i'm happy i'm here now i
wanted to get rid of yeah you know some
of the some of the most important people
in history have come from those
conditions
um i i think it's become
both an easy way out but also kind of a
point of control for some women who are
a little more malicious with it
yeah no i absolutely agree well thank
you for calling in appreciate it
i love the show i'm happy with what
you're doing i'm happy there's a
semblance of sanity coming back and um
keep keep doing a great job
thank you have a good one me too bye
bye
[Music]
andrew dennis why are you back in here i
see you in the back you were trolling
already i'm kicking you're getting
kicked kicked
yeah the audacity okay
um
okay let's go
courtney lynn camera on
you are up hello
how are you i'm good
i'm how are you doing tonight
um very well
um so what do you think is it a woman's
right to choose
no no
i thought you might disagree with me
it's okay
no
i already had a child so
oh yeah okay so um why not
uh because you're killing a kid you know
that's the whole
um do you fight do you know anyone
that's had an abortion
no
oh you don't know a single person
no or not anyone that's disclosed that
to me i guess oh okay
because um the interesting thing i found
out was that like everyone i know that's
had an abortion was just irresponsible
it wasn't like a
a last resort type of thing it was no no
birth control at all with the wrong guy
that's the
sadly the majority of the cases
now question do you as a woman feel like
we can control ourselves to the point we
could maybe use abstinence
yeah
and if that doesn't work could we
possibly use birth control
oh yeah yeah i've personally done both
and uh yeah
and do you
do you feel like do you feel like you
are disadvantaged and discriminated
against because you wouldn't possibly
have a right to abortion
no
no do you feel like you're okay
i think i'm all right
okay
well thank you for calling in courtney
appreciate it oh yeah you too have a
good one bye
all right
another one okay see
i'm sorry men i gave women priority i'm
sorry
hello
hi
how are you
i'm good
um
i was just
thinking about
because i'm i'm pro-life so i don't
really have any
um disagreements
okay but have you heard of um kristen
hawkins
ah no i haven't who is that she um she
goes around to like different campuses
and
debates
college students about
abortion
and sometimes the
logic is really flawed
on some of those so like i remember i
recall once like
um
this
girl was saying that
if um
a mother who crossed the border
and her child
that she brought over with her
um
was like on the verge of death
that we should help that baby survive
but
a baby that was
that survived abortion
um that we should not help but survive
and
yeah
yeah
it was really crazy and
so so if the baby survived they wouldn't
give it medical care
that's what the
this person who is advocating for
oh my gosh yeah it's crazy stuff like
that and um
also like the whole um
not wanting to the child to be poor like
grow up in poverty
is kind of elitist you know
i'm sorry you can't say my hand is up
[Laughter]
because like um
it
then you like only
you know people
who are rich can have children
right yeah and like
oh goodbye to africa goodbye to india
you know
it's like why is the life less valuable
because it would grow up in foster care
because that's always what i hear is oh
you don't want more kids in foster care
i'm like are they less valuable
right
and i think the solution would be
improving the adoption system possibly
maybe not definitely awarding the
children
right i think uh abortion like they
why does it have to go to the extreme
you know like there's so many options
out there
um like the adoption or
you know they even have like
you can if you don't even want to go
through the shame of like
you know people knowing that you you did
that because some people are like that
um because they don't want to feel like
you're going to judge them
you can go to like the
fire department
and drop your baby off there and they'll
find someone for or to take care of that
baby
so
um
they're different options and
um
you can go to your local churches
they're couples in those churches that
can't conceive and they're wanting
um to have babies so
i mean
there's a lot
like i've
um
heard couples saying that they've been
on a waiting list for like two and a
half years
for for a baby to adopt so i mean
there there's people willing
yeah
no i don't i don't actually know why
it's so hard because it seems like i
always hear about foster care being so
backed up but i also hear about so many
people that want to adopt so i don't
know what
the disconnect is but it seems like that
would be a better solution rather than
just aborting children
right
right well
thank you for calling in um
it's always nice to see there's other
women that agree with me but
yeah uh appreciate it have a good one
thank you too
sorry i accidentally kicked myself
does anyone disagree with me behind the
cameras
anyone disagree okay you okay
kinda no don't kind of me
you disagree or you don't disagree okay
then sorry
hello yo what up
what's up how are you
i'm very good appreciate what you're
doing here
you always seem like a level-headed and
pretty based
chick and i can appreciate that
i have a different viewpoint
i don't like
i hate to be like one of those i don't
totally disagree with you but when you
make so much sense a lot of people are
gonna agree right
okay yeah yeah
i always viewed it like this because
like we're millennials and [ __ ] like
that so my whole life
abortion's always been a thing
right so it's like i never thought
it's clear that it's bad it's clear that
it's some type of
immoral act
whether you engaged in it or not
you know
my whole life has been
upon a person's personal morals to make
that decision right
so i didn't necessarily support rolling
that back
um
but i wonder why there's no like causes
even on people who are like pro-choice
to try to reduce it it always seems like
they they view abortion like
it's some kind of virtue or some kind of
cool thing to do i always felt like
since i'm a guy like we always have to
take responsibility in reproductive
situations like there's never been like
a
oh make a choice like the choice is
either wrap it up or not
mm-hmm
and
like women
have it in their hands
like they if you get a girl pregnant
she has you by the boss nowadays so to
speak you know right
men don't really get that choice like
quite frankly
you know we talk about a woman's right
to her body
if a man
gets the girl pregnant
has no say in the situation right
she has the baby he's obligated to care
for that baby say she puts him on child
support
if she doesn't pay that shot if he
doesn't pay that child support
his body
can then literally be thrown in jail
right yes yes
so i just feel like
if there's an out route
for women
then and i don't support this i would be
the you know i'm i'm
i would like to think i'm a man of god
right
i would support if i don't have any kids
but if it came down to it i would
support
but men should maybe
if we're gonna roll that route and allow
like women to have out route
men should have out route too
no i agree with you um quick question
what makes you did you say you still
think that women should have the right
to an abortion in the beginning
i've also been you know as a man growing
up in this day and age you get shamed
out of really having a hardcore opinion
on it at all
i'm not gonna lie i feel like
there are a lot of things that are evil
in society
that we're allowed to do in america
unfortunately
and i wasn't necessarily in support of
rolling it back i wasn't upset when they
wrote it back i kind of
like
i i think that
do you think it's a baby
do you think it's life
that it starts at conception here's the
thing
it makes no sense to say it's not a baby
because
even if you say it's only sales if you
have a basic knowledge of science
cells are literally the building blocks
of what
yeah yeah yeah so
in science we learned that atoms are
just like
potentially non-living basic building
blocks sales are living
by definition and
you know it's it's interesting when they
say it's not
you know we get a lot of liberals
i really see some of these people's
motivations like
quite frankly i i read a post by the
aclu today
on ig i'm not sure if anybody else has
seen it
but it was very interesting they gave
some reasons why it's so horrible that
roe v wade was rolled back
the reasons were that
uh
it will make it difficult and i wrote
these down actually in case you gave me
the honor to be up here right
it makes it difficult to escape poverty
okay
it may derail education
career and life plans
and
it'll make it more difficult to leave an
abusive partner
you know
these were the reasons they gave why
women should have the right to abortion
they're not really good ones and i
and i as a guy i kind of look at it like
and i got a lot of women in my family i
got a lot of love but i just look i try
to look at everything objectively like
even i would like to think if i were a
woman i would flip it and just try to
look at it sometimes like that too
if i were to say
yeah um i got this girl pregnant but
it's going to be a bad idea if she has
it because uh it's going to stop me from
escaping poverty
that's actually a really good control
your [ __ ] dick like keep your dick in
your pants wrap it up for something
if you can't escape poverty like you
shouldn't probably be [ __ ] excuse my
language like i'm going to use this
argument actually like she's crazy the
guy said that i've never thought about
it like that this looks really good
yeah
yeah uh sweetheart
oh you're pregnant um
i need you to get rid of it because it's
gonna derail my education my career in
life plans
so like
i just like kind of i try to be balanced
like i said
um
it caught me way off guard when they
rolled it back i never in my wildest
dreams thought that would really happen
you know what i mean and
like i said i'm i'm i'm an altruistic
guy i don't like even though i may
disagree i don't like seeing
the crazy levels of disappointment i
would hope that with the extra life
being born
maybe those that are like-minded like me
those that are christians
and that sort of thing or just like
well-minded people who are pro-life
maybe we could try to
put our money where our mouth is and get
involved in maybe the community care for
some of the extra life or lend a hand to
somebody that may be having trouble with
a child that they had unexpectedly
you know what i mean kind of that
communal sense of things i wanted to ask
you um
[Music]
a question if that's fine
yeah that's okay um
you're very conscious of like the
origins of planned parenthood and all
these sort of things and how
abortion and in many cases forms of
contraception were used as uh
eugenics
many on the
left-wing side and i definitely wouldn't
identify with that side of things
oh definitely not like i saw people at
these rallies with like dolls of
a dog of like a baby bleeding and like
yeah i'm killing the baby what are you
gonna do about it i'm like this [ __ ] is
sick
but
[Music]
one thing that they did say was that um
and and that i did see potential
evidence of
um
and it was interesting
was that
many right-wingers
may support pro-life not because they're
really like these well-meaning
good-hearted people
many see the demographics of america
changing
okay and
contrary to the kind of argument for
poverty most people who get abortions
are middle class
most people who get abortions are middle
class or higher
um
which would disproportionately affect
the so-called white population right
and many feel like
it's kind of like a place in many cases
for
the more alt-right types or something to
get the birth rate up for
the white population and kind of balance
out
the shrinking majority what are your
thoughts on that
well if they're if the right is
supporting eugenics wouldn't they want
abortion because the black black women
have a 50 birth rate
no with without a doubt
to that just playing devil's advocate
one would say you know
the growing latino population or
immigrants many immigrants of you know
more
brownish kind of kind of
stock
um maybe
you know driving
the white population to no longer have
the majority in america
and if they could stop you know
abortions from occurring in middle class
potential and even poor white
populations that
it could cause some balance over the
next generation or so
so you're saying that pro like that the
argument is that pro-lifers want to get
rid of abortion so we can have a more
people in the middle class that are
white
that's the argument more white babies
more white people
okay um i mean it just wouldn't make
sense because if their goal was to
if that was their goal wouldn't they be
pro-choice because black women abort
more than other races and number two i
don't really think
i don't really think you're ever going
to know people's real intentions so i
don't i think like arguing about
people's intentions is kind of pointless
um i think what makes more sense is
arguing about the evidence and
what results policies have on
populations so
it's possible
but you're just you're just never gonna
know
no without a doubt i hear you on that
and you don't know people's motives i
just wanted to hear what you thought
about that because there's always like
it's crazy how they point the you know
both sides are going to point the finger
at each other
and and claim the same thing
who's more who's more or less racist
who's
less caring about the community and that
sort of thing so i just thought i'd get
your thoughts on that what's your
thought on um
what are your thoughts on [ __ ] like plan
b
um i don't have a strong opinion on plan
b
because i don't honestly know a lot
about it um the more i'm learning i've
heard that it actually like i've heard
people say that it is similar to an
abortion i've heard people say it's not
so i don't
yeah i wouldn't
i don't have a strong opinion because i
don't know enough about
it nice nice
yeah i i uh
i don't know if i know that many people
who did an abortion a lot of people
aren't gonna talk about it but i know
[ __ ] ton of people who have used
that
i don't know the science behind it but
i just thought i'd ask you seem like a
very hard-line pro-lifer
and that's cool like that's that's a
pretty like based opinion in my in my
view you know what i'm saying like
um i just thought i'd ask you about that
overall like
i think that um
these decisions like it's interesting to
me that we've gotten to a point in
america where
even when people are defending abortion
unfortunately
they're framing it in such a way like
oh you know it should be a woman's
choice and that like there's no
conversation about maybe it should be
the family's choice
like between
the woman and the man who created the
baby like there's no
and don't get me wrong
it is a huge commendable burden enormous
commendable burden women have to take on
to carry a child you know what i mean
like
but
i unfortunately have seen situations
where
you know even potential relatives of
mine have gotten like dragged through
the ringer and like treated like dog
[ __ ] like they didn't have anything to
do with making that child
and it's like
and they're men
right
and um
i think that uh
we've gotten to a point in america where
they're kind of like
destroying families in many in so many
different ways like
and uh
maybe hopefully the results of this
could result in
you know
maybe things getting more back to normal
as far as gender relations
i don't know what the outcome's going to
be
right
hopefully for better for worse like
it'll it'll increase gender relations in
a good way
well thank you for calling in i
appreciate it
appreciate you
okay have a good one you too
okay i want to get this hello
hi pearl
how are you
hi
hi
so what's what's your opinion is it a
woman's
right when does life begin
so
i was on the left
up until like the day
donald trump was elected i remember
waking up
and the media telling me
abortion rights will be taken away and
being a college educated female in the
liberal space
feeling like it was the end of the world
and then
having
woken up
in a moment where i connected and heard
the story of someone that was a relative
of mine
that i loved very dearly who
chose to have an abortion
many many years ago
and
learning about the amount of regret
and the
pain and
problems conceiving afterwards and
that's changed my mind completely
because i think a lot of it is that
women
think they have a choice but is it
really a choice if you don't understand
what the choices that you're making
like
again it's an ideological possession
more than an understanding of truth and
reality and what the consequences are
down the law
what made you so
was there something specific that that
woman said to you um outside of just
that she regretted it like did you learn
more about the abortion procedure
so i actually know a lot of women
personally of different ages who have
had abortions
um
some with the pill
which from my understanding is that
experience is very painful for some
women
um emotionally and physically definitely
um and then some who have had the
surgery
and
i know a lot
a lot of women um talking between ages
60
to
25.
and yeah like in having multiple
and
that's their choice and i i can't speak
of how they
actually really feel about it but just
hearing from all of them
a lot of people
honestly what i also see is
it's almost like
i think you had a
a girl on earlier who spoke about how
the guy shut her down and so she decided
to go and get the abortion
and i've seen that a lot
or i've heard that a lot
where women
are presented with this choice
that they don't want to make a loan
but at the end of the day if the guy is
not
wanting to be there that deep sense of
rejection at the same time of also
dealing with this crisis
i think leads them to that path now i
also know a girl a woman
who
chose to go the other way
and
chose to keep her baby
and she ended up going back to she
cleaned up her act
after she got pregnant and she went back
to school
she's an attorney like she she's
incredibly successful a beautiful mom
has a beautiful baby boy and
you know when when she made that choice
i did everything i could to support her
because i feel like that is what women
are missing like there's a
shame to getting pregnant out of wedlock
and also a deep shame to having abortion
and so i really wish that
there was
less women saying oh you can get an
abortion it's fine and more women
connecting
with their friends and their loved ones
and trying to understand and trying to
be there for them really regardless of
what choice they make
do you think that women um ever get
pregnant intentionally
because sometimes i have a hard time
believing when a lot of girls
these guys that like don't clearly want
them that it was an accidental pregnancy
like sometimes i think girls get
pregnant in hopes that it'll bring them
together
which is a bad plan
and then when it doesn't work then they
get the abortion
um
and i don't think a lot of girls admit
to it but
i just think as a woman we can kind of
put two and two together
yeah i think it's it's a toxic
relationship
that you know both parties are
manipulating each other
you know like
they're they're taking advantage of each
other not feeding off of each other's
bad energy i guess i'm not really sure
they're not really there for the
commitment to to help each other be
better human beings
right um i have seen that i have seen
that and it has come out to be even
harder for the woman to end up making
that choice realizing oh i put myself
out there i tried to cuddle this man
and
i'm still rejected i've still seen
people go through the decision of having
an abortion because of that also you
know
but i know that there are women that
will try to get pregnant and try to live
yeah
like i'm not saying it you know it goes
either way but i think there's a
spiritual
crisis that women also have to face and
you know be more accountable
yeah do you think we should i think we
should bring back shame
yeah
yeah like i think i think we should be
ashamed of
getting an abortion and having
getting pregnant outside of
marriage yeah
like i was brought up with a moral
compass i always knew that like abortion
was the last thing i would ever want to
do
but that doesn't take away the fact that
it was always available
like we were an abstinence only
education but it really wasn't that like
people were doing things all the time no
one ever really told you
what were the consequences so yeah
or do you feel
like your rights are being taken away
no
really it should
like i
again like i get it i i sure
there are a very very very small
percentage of women
they
it would be a medical procedure
not not birth control not an option to
go to a planned parenthood clinic and
also
i'm talking about the plan b situation
so plan b you can get over the counter
you don't have to get a prescription you
can just walk into a walgreens and say
hey i want plan b and they'll give that
out like to anybody
and we don't know the consequences of
things like that either
um as well as
things like birth control like how is
that going to affect you long term like
i have been personally pushed by many
many of my friends
innocently that oh you have a headache
oh you have a bad period oh you have
this going on take birth control it
fixes everything like that's not the
right answer also
no i don't know why we're pushing women
so young to get on birth control i mean
i was only on it for like a year or two
and i never really had side effects but
i just didn't like the idea that like
i could long term
and so i like got off of it young but i
don't understand why
like at 15 14 some girls are getting on
birth control
and it's like we're almost encouraging
promiscuous behavior and that's the most
valuable thing women have yeah like that
we were just born with is your purity
yeah we're encouraging young girls to
just give it up for what
i feel like if this
i know people would probably hate me for
saying this i think it's kind of a
victory at least to the point of
i do hope it changes the culture's
mindset and
women's mindset and their value their
self-worth
their ability to say no
because they know that there are
consequences
like i hope that that kind of changes
the trajectory of how women value
themselves i think someone else even
said it's like you know you can do
whatever you want there's there's no
consequences
that's a huge problem it's a huge there
are consequences in life
and there are consequences even if
you're not aware of it
yeah so
yeah
well thank you so much for calling in
you were so sweet
nice talking people bye nice talking to
you
okay um
i'm sorry to everyone that's been
waiting in the back
i'm sorry i'm ending the stream it's 4am
here
okay guys let me i'm sorry i'm kicking
all of you thank you for waiting it's
just not today there's a lot of you i'm
sorry
i'm sorry okay so
um thank you i'm gonna read the super
chats real quick um some of the people
that have sent them
sorry if i missed some but
i appreciate you all this is going
towards new camera equipment mgtow by
logic does the father have a right to
know many times abortions
oh that's a good question many abortions
are don't tell
are done without telling the man is that
fraud to them to continue to take a
man's money and time
um artists five dollars does anyone
think about the reversal of roe versus
wade has to do with birth rates across
the world even china has a baby rule
um
okay um aaron no matter where you stand
on abortion this decision was the
correct one the constitution makes no
mention of the right to an abortion i'm
celebrating it
okay um
mgtow by logic wrong pre-1965 the
welfare state marriage in a family and
the stability that that both created and
required to let people out of poverty
did create poverty
um stop sleeping our checks stop
sleeping around and living with no
consequent i'm glad the ruling was
turned over this country is to get back
to some semblance of morality and
normalcy okay um
okay guys i am so tired because it's
like 4 a.m here
i need you guys ideas
of how to get more women that disagree
with me i really would like to talk to
women that disagree with me and i'm
having a hard time apparently women that
disagree with me don't watch me so
if you guys have any ideas or women that
you can send to me please dm me on
instagram it's just up pearly things
sign up for my memberships for exclusive
behind the scenes content we're also
getting a discord
i don't know how but we are doing
discord and
i love you guys you're the best i'll
talk to you next time bye